Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Die Ratten fressen jetzt unsere Glasfaserleitungen auf.
Es bleibt das beste Netz, das wir haben.
Musik,
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 545 vom 3. Februar 2026.
Und ja, wir begrüßen euch im besten Podcast.
Ja.
Das blenden wir jetzt auch rechts oben ein, wenn ihr mal so kurz...
Animiert.
Ja, wenn ihr mal so in eurem gefühlten Bild, was ihr jetzt gerade im Kopf habt,
weil so erlebt man ja Podcasts.
Man hat immer so blühende Landschaften und dazu unsere beruhigenden Stimmen.
Und rechts oben ist da jetzt so eine Einblendung.
Bester Podcast.
Im besten Podcast. Besser im besten Podcast. Besser im besten Podcast.
Frischer Spritze. Frischer Spritze.
Leute, echt wirklich. Also die Telekom leistet es sich jetzt.
Ich meine, jetzt bin ich das erste Mal froh, dass ich keinen Telekom-Vertrag habe.
Aber sie weiß nicht wirklich den wie heißt denn das eigentlich offiziell,
die Netzbezeichnung, Netzkennung, die auf den Telefonen Carrier.
Identifier oder sowas?
Ja, sowas. Für einen Werbeslogan zu missbrauchen.
Und ich finde, ich finde,
Das sind so diese Momente, wo man einfach mal die Marketingabteilung,
das Kokain wegnehmen sollte.
Ne, ne, ne.
Mehr.
Wenn du dir das Kokain wegnimmst, dann werden die knatschig.
Guck mal, du musst ja auch mal das Genie entdecken, ja.
Das waren wirklich so die letzten Pixel auf dem Smartphone-Display,
wo einfach noch keiner geschafft hat, Werbung zu platzieren.
Und die haben gedacht, Da können wir Werbung platzieren.
Das, was noch nicht so schlau ist und der Gedanke, den die jetzt erst bald haben
werden, ist, die machen da ja Werbung für sich bei ihren eigenen Kunden.
Das wird denen früher oder später auffallen, dass sie dadurch,
das ist ja eine Werbemaßnahme, wo jetzt quasi kein erkennbarer Abtick in neuen
Verträgen erkennbar sein wird, weil sich diese Werbemaßnahme an Leute richtet,
die schon ihre Kunden sind.
Das ist das, was denen auffällt, wenn die entweder mehr Kokain kriegen oder weniger.
Eins von beiden, früher oder später wird diese Erkenntnis einsetzen.
Und dann werden die auf die Idee kommen und sagen, ja, okay,
wer hat denn Bock bei uns?
Ist ja total dumm, dass wir bei unseren Kunden für uns werben.
Wofür könnten wir denn noch bei
unseren Kunden werben? Und dann kommt da demnächst Pampers und sonst was.
Bitte ein Bit oder wenn es um Geld geht, Sparkasse oder so. Das kann man da
alles oben reinschreiben.
Und das Schöne ist, wenn du lange Sätze nimmst, wie dieser, dann scrollt das
auch durch und macht ein komplett nervöses Gezappel da oben auf dem Display. Super.
Also da hat wahrscheinlich einer mal irgendwie Internetgeschichte nachgeschlagen.
Erinnerst du dich noch an die Million Dollar Homepage?
Wo der ein Pixel verkauft hat für einen Dollar.
Ein Pixel für einen Dollar. Also der hat einfach eine Webseite gemacht,
die gibt es auch heute noch, milliondollarhomepage.com.
Und dort ist eine Grafik zu sehen, die besteht aus 1000 mal 1000 Pixel.
Und er hat dann jeden Pixel für einen Dollar verkauft und damit dann eine Million Dollar eingenommen.
Vollidiot, 1000 mal 1000 Pixel.
So bleibst du halt Millionär. Also da hätte ich auf jeden Fall die Billion-Dollar-Homepage,
direkt noch mitregistriert, aber dafür hat die Million wahrscheinlich nicht mehr gereicht.
Also ich hätte ehrlich gesagt, also ich war damals glaube ich nicht schnell genug.
Ich muss mich mal so richtig überlegen. Wobei jetzt das Umfeld,
in dem man da wirbt, das ist ein bisschen zweifelhaft.
Aber es sind schon ein paar lustige Sachen drin.
Zum Beispiel Even Monkeys Fall From Trees steht hier irgendwo auf der Seite und.
Das ist Werbung für Monkeys oder für Trees.
The Book of Cool Learn From The Best,
Bookofcool.com gucken wir mal ob es das noch gibt Squarespace,
Website Expired siehste mal die könnten wir uns sozusagen holen The Book of
Cool und dann linken wir einfach,
Dann linken wir einfach auf unseren Podcast.
Ja.
So macht man das nämlich heutzutage.
Jetzt muss ich noch erklären, warum die Ratten uns das Internet wegessen.
Das ist vielleicht was, ist genauso alt wie diese Million Dollar Webpage.
Ich finde, die Ratten, die sollten sich jetzt wirklich mal ein bisschen auf
die Telekom ein bisschen konzentrieren, damit die mit ihrem komischen Claim
des besten letztes Mal richtig schön auf der Nase landen.
Aber bevor wir zu den Ratten kommen, muss ich echt nochmal sagen,
dass ich diesen Move einfach zutiefst verabscheue.
Und ich finde, das sollte einfach mal von der Bnetz A bestraft werden,
sodass jetzt sozusagen die Kennungen da vorgegeben werden.
Und dann dürfen sie da nur noch, dann darf da nur noch T stehen und nichts anderes.
Ich fände irgendeine richtig schöne,
Bundesrepublik. Irgendwie das Festtab der Neuzeit. Weißt du,
irgendwie so eine Fetab.
Fufnko.
Funknetz für mobile Kommunikation oder,
Mobdafune. Mobdafune A. Und dann Mobdafune B. oder sowas.
Vorschläge für die richtige Abkürzung in die Kommentare, bitte.
Irgendwas richtig, richtig, so ein richtiges Schande. So ein Schandemerkmal.
Strafe. Dass jeder, der jeden Tag auf sein Handy guckt, sagt,
da steht Mubdafune und nicht besser im besten Netz.
Das haben sie davon. Dass Leute, so wie du jetzt, ich weiß nicht zum wievielten
Mal von der Million Dollar Webpage erzählst, Das erste Mal. Nee, nein.
Doch.
Und dann, so werden Leute dann auch sagen, wisst ihr noch damals,
wisst ihr noch wie Mobdafone 1B,
Damals, die hießen Telekom, die waren Magenta. Und dann haben sie sich die Finger
verbrannt an unserer Regulierungswut.
Und dann haben wir sie umbenannt in Mobdafune.
Und jetzt steht da so eine Scheiße bei uns statt Werbung.
Und dann werden die Kinder sagen, was ist denn so schlimm an Werbung? Auf dem Handy.
Uns wird die Werbung hier ins Gehirn geballert. Über den Schlüssel,
den die uns da reingerammt hat.
Weil ihr dafür 3,80 Euro im Monat bekommen habt oder so. Das wird eine wunderschöne
Geschichte, die man dann noch erzählen kann.
Ja, also auf jeden Fall die Ratten haben es auf die Glasfaser gar nicht so sehr
abgesehen, sondern auf die Glasfaserummantelung und das ist ja auch nachvollziehbar,
weil die müssen ja ihre Zähne schleifen, die armen Viecher, weil die immer nachwachsen.
Aber das Problem ist, dass jetzt in England jemand sich gedacht hat,
oder ich weiß gar nicht, ob das nicht vielleicht sogar eine Vorgabe war.
Das kann ich mir jetzt nicht vorstellen.
Oder ich vermute mal, es war keine Vorgabe, sondern so ein Wir benutzen jetzt
oder wir machen das jetzt hier mal nachhaltig.
Besondere Ökoglasfaser. Aus Maisstärke den Kunststoff da drum, ne?
Mais und Soja, genau. Die sie da sozusagen mit in diesen Kunststoff reingemischt
haben, damit das sozusagen weniger Plastik enthält. Das ist so ein bisschen wie EZ.
Wollten die, dass die kompostiert werden?
Keine Ahnung. Auf jeden Fall scheinen die Ratten, die sonst irgendwie ab und
zu mal in so ein Kabel reinknabbern, da so richtig Freude dran gefunden zu haben.
Warum? Naja, klar, weil das riecht nach richtigem Essen.
Ja, und das führt in dem Fall dazu,
dass die präferiert halt die Fasern von genau diesem einen Unternehmen essen
und dem Unternehmen geht es ohnehin nicht so gut und die würden gerne gekauft
werden und jetzt gab es halt so eine Due Diligence Prüfung, bei der dann eben rauskam, ja,
Ratten,
von führenden Ratten empfohlen.
Das beste Netz.
Und das kostet dir jetzt im Zweifelsfall den Verkauf, weil natürlich ein Netz,
klar, es ist seine Kunden wert, aber natürlich auch nur, solange du in der Lage bist,
diese Kunden weiterhin im Vertragsverhältnis zu halten.
Und wenn die Ratten dir das Netz wegfressen und die Konkurrenz da so ein schönes Chemokabel nebenlegt,
dann ist dein Netz nicht mehr viel wert.
So ist das. Naja, kommen wir zu den wichtigen Dingen im Leben.
Netze, die nichts wert sind oder viel wert sind. TikTok.
Ja, TikTok. TikTok ist ja ein großer Erfolg.
So groß, so großer Erfolg, dass die USA direkt gesagt haben, Mensch,
das bedroht ja unsere nationale Sicherheit, wenn jetzt hier auf einmal alle
rumrennen und dieses soziale Netz benutzen,
da kann man uns ja drüber abhören und kontrollieren, das wollen wir so nicht,
wir wollen bitte, dass das unter US-Kontrolle kommt.
Genau, das war so die Argumentation der Trump-Regierung. Das ging ja auch lange
Zeit hin und her. Also es war dann immer von einem Verbot die Rede.
Ja, TikTok ist ja ganz furchtbar, das geht ja gar nicht. Die Chinesen,
die machen ja hier Propaganda, die nicht von uns gesteuert wird.
Und dann ging es immer hin und her und dann haben sie es wieder verlängert und so weiter.
Also es lief so auf ein TikTok-Verbot hinaus, was natürlich sehr unpopulär gewesen wäre,
also bei den Leuten, die TikTok verwenden und das sind ja eine Menge, vor allem junge Leute.
Viele beziehen darüber ihre Nachrichten und das ist halt so ein Social Feed, der einfach mal noch,
süchtig machender zu sein scheint, als das schon mit Instagram der Fall war
also ich meine heutzutage sieht man ja die Welt echt nur noch swipen und nicht mehr so richtig,
ja ich weiß auch nicht liest doch mal wieder Blogs.
Ja also ist uns allen natürlich klar, wie attraktiv das ist und uns ist natürlich auch klar,
dass die Algorithmen, die da bei TikTok unterwegs sind, hochproblematisch sind.
Also ich habe mal TikTok ohne Account mal frisch irgendwie aufgemacht.
Da dauert es nicht lange, bis du dir von irgendwelchen AfD-Jüngern erzählst,
dass die Welt kurz vor dem Untergang steht und jetzt müsste man mal durchgegriffen werden.
Das ist alles überhaupt gar kein Spaß.
Naja, das ist der Trump-Regierung natürlich dann auch schnell klar geworden,
dass das ein Propagandamittel erster Qualität ist, aber man hat halt nicht so
viel Einfluss auf die Leute in China.
Also haben sie gesagt, wenn ihr das jetzt in den USA weiter betreiben wollt,
dann müsst ihr das verkaufen und das ist jetzt geschehen.
Ja, aber also,
Ich bewundere ja gewissermaßen, wie konsequent die USA mit dieser Bedrohung
eines fremdkontrollierten sozialen Netzwerks mit nennenswerter Reichweite in
ihrem Land umgegangen sind.
Also man könnte ja fast sagen, warum macht Europa das eigentlich nicht mit den
US-amerikanischen Netzwerken,
insbesondere wenn man sich überlegt, dass auf X ja immer noch Politikerinnen posten und versuchen,
inmitten von irgendwelchen KI-generierten, sexualisierten Darstellungen von
Kindern und Frauen irgendwie politische Botschaften zu positionieren.
Aber interessant ist auch nochmal, wer sind denn dann diejenigen,
die in so einem Joint-Venture, wem gehört denn jetzt TikTok?
Das gehört zu jeweils 15% Oracle, Silver Lake und MGX und MGX ist irgendwie
der Investment-Arm von...
Und Shaikh Tahun bin Sayed al-Nayan,
ich habe es jetzt nach dem besten meiner Möglichkeiten ausgesprochen und das
ist der stellvertretende Herrscher von Abu Dhabi und der National Security Advisor
der Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate.
Also 15% davon gehört jetzt den Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten.
Dann Oracle 15%, Silver Lake 15% und dann noch so The Dell Family Office,
also so der private Investmentarm von Michael Dell, der ja Dell Technologies gegründet hat.
Vast mere strategic investments, Alpha Wave Partners, Revolution,
Merit Way, die haben wieder ein paar Untergruppierungen und ByteDance gehören noch 19,9 Prozent.
Also sie bleiben der größte Eigner, aber eben auch ein Minderheiteneigner und
durch die 3 mal 15 Prozent brauchen Silver Lake Oracle und MGX jetzt nur von
den anderen wenige Prozent,
um halt die komplette Mehrheit darüber zu haben. Ich glaube, am Ende wird da,
ist es eine faszinierende.
Einfach nur ein faszinierender Vorgang, dass die USA das einfach nur gesagt
haben, dieser Markt wird nicht passieren, wir verbieten euch sonst,
Und hier sind jetzt die Leute, die demnächst Teilhaber werden,
die Kontrolle übernehmen und eben auch die Kohle kassieren.
Und dann sehen wir mal, wie das läuft.
Ja, also wohlgemerkt, nicht TikTok ist verkauft worden, sondern nur TikTok USA ist verkauft worden.
Ja.
Und ja, das ist auf jeden Fall alles eine ordentlich shady Riege.
Also dieser Scheich, den du da gerade benannt hast, ich habe gerade mal so ein
bisschen nachgeschlagen, Er hat also wirklich auch eine interessante Vergangenheit.
Blumenreiner Demokrat wahrscheinlich.
Ja, ja, ja. Er hat schon diverse EU-Sanktionen unterlaufen, um irgendwie Bashar
al-Assad da zu unterstützen.
Und irgendwie hat das russische Sputnik, den Sputnik-Impfstoff,
diesen Corona-Impfstoff, den sie rausgebracht hat, irgendwie mit viel Gewinn
an arme Länder versucht zu verkaufen.
Und noch so ein paar Bestechungsskandale und Hass nicht gesehen.
Naja, aber das ist, ja, so läuft das da halt.
Und das Foto in der Wikipedia musst du dir mal unbedingt anschauen.
Also der Typ würde eigentlich jetzt normalerweise so in die USA nicht anreisen
können, wie der aussieht.
Geile Sonnenbrille.
Die anderen Investoren, die ich da gerade noch so halb gelistet habe,
das sind bestehende Investoren.
Also neu sind Tiktor, diese Silver Lake, Oracle und MGX. Und die übernehmen
jetzt die Verantwortung für Datenschutz und Inhaltsmoderation in den USA.
Die werden also sagen, welche Inhalte hier verbreitet werden,
wie der Algorithmus getunt wird und Oracle wird dann eben noch die Einhaltung
der nationalen Sicherheitsstandards überwachen, die Nutzerdaten hosten und den Algorithmus anpassen.
Das ist schon echt.
What could possibly go wrong, ja.
Naja, also so macht man es halt, ne?
Oracle gehört Larry Ellison, der mittlerweile, glaube ich, der zweitreichste.
Zweitreichste auf jeden Fall. Irgendwann mal zwischendurch, je nachdem,
was Elon Musk füttert, ist auch immer kurzfristig der reichste.
Ja, also auf jeden Fall alles sehr zweifelhaft und es bleibt alles fest in der
Hand der Oligarchen, die sich da in den USA immer mehr in Stellung bringen.
Ja, das ist offensichtlich das Ziel der amerikanischen Regierung,
da sozusagen so ein Oligarchensystem nach russischem Vorbild aufzuziehen.
Naja, also immerhin, also unabhängig von, was man jetzt von dieser amerikanischen
Regierung und ihren Zielen und so weiter hält,
und das ist natürlich nichts Gutes, Aber immerhin haben sie die Gefahr einer
komplett fremdgesteuerten Aufmerksamkeits- und Meinungskontrollmaschine im eigenen
Land erkannt und eine Lösung dafür gefunden,
indem sie die jetzt unter ihre Kontrolle bringen.
Ja, das ist etwas, was die Europäische Union ja grundsätzlich auch versucht
mit so ein bisschen, sagen wir mal, softeren Versuchen, ja?
Ja.
Aber grundsätzlich ist das, also das Ziel ist das gleiche.
Hier zeigt man, hier sieht man jetzt halt mal, wie es die Profis machen,
die uns schon Facebook und X und Instagram und was nicht alles übergeholfen haben.
Also ich bezweifle, dass die Ziele die gleichen sind.
Formal, formal ist es genau das gleiche.
Ja, formal. Aber das sind nicht die eigentlichen Ziele, sondern es wird natürlich
genauso dieser Algorithmus einfach genutzt werden, wie das mit den anderen Algorithmen auch ist,
um da einfach eine bestimmte Sichtweise der Welt mehr in den Vordergrund zu
stellen als andere Sichtweisen der Welt.
Das ist richtig.
Formal bleibt das Problem aber natürlich, dass die Regierungen eine Form der
Kontrolle darüber haben wollen, wie diese Netzwerke funktionieren und wo nicht.
Also nochmal, ich weiß auch, dass die USA hier etwas sehr Böses im Schilde führen
und ich weiß, dass die EU im Zweifelsfall etwas nicht ganz so Böses im Schilde führt.
Und gleichwohl reagieren sie hier auf das gleiche Problem.
Ja, na gut. Ich meine, für die USA ist es natürlich ein Schock,
dass es überhaupt ein soziales Netzwerk oder eine nennenswert digitale Infrastruktur
auf dem Planeten gibt, die ihnen nicht gehört.
Die sie nicht ohne weiteres unter ihrer Kontrolle oder ohne weiteres unter ihrer
Regulierung, also unter ihrer Regulierung könnten sie sie in gewisser Hinsicht bringen.
Das Problem ist nur, sie müssten ja dann Regeln aufstellen, wo sich auch die
eigenen dran halten müssen. Da ist Europa, glaube ich, noch ein bisschen anders aufgestellt.
Nicht, dass jetzt Europa nicht auch zurückschrecken würde. Gäbe es überhaupt
irgendeine nennenswerte digitale Infrastruktur von weltweiter Bedeutung in Europa,
dann sähe das halt auch etwas anders aus.
Und es gibt ja so ansatzweise hier und da, Spotify und so.
Dann sieht man die Dinge gegebenenfalls auch nochmal ein bisschen anders,
aber es spielt sich halt alles noch auf so einer Ebene der einheitlichen Regulierung,
ab, was ich auch nach wie vor für den richtigen Weg halte.
Oder denkst du das jetzt irgendwie Facebook-Deutschland sollte jetzt von Aldi gekauft werden?
Instagram, wer kauft es? Willst du was haben, Linus? Was hättest du denn gern?
Ich kaufe, was kaufe ich? Nichts. Ich kaufe nichts. Ich kaufe nichts an der Tür.
Du kaufst, ich kaufe nichts.
Ich kaufe nichts. Heute nicht. Aber zumindest sieht man doch mal hier,
wie ich finde es auf jeden Fall interessant, wie die USA einerseits,
wie die sich echauffieren über,
die Europäische Union voll gemein. Die wollen hier die Meinungsfreiheit einschränken,
die nutzen ihre politische Macht, um unsere schönen Plattformen einzuschränken. Ja?
Und vielleicht, vielleicht, vielleicht, vielleicht, vielleicht,
vielleicht sollte die Europäische Union auch einfach mal sagen, pass auf, wisst ihr was?
Wir haben uns überlegt, ihr verkauft den Scheiß jetzt oder wir machen das zu.
Fertig, fertig, zack, hier.
So, wen haben wir da? Was sind bei uns so die sympathischen Personen mit Geld?
Gut, die sind bei uns nicht ganz so auffällig wie in den USA.
Ja, dann, was weiß ich, wie heißt die, Quant und Schwarz.
Klatten und Schwarz.
Und wen könnten wir noch? Wie heißt dieser Anlagebetrüger da? Maschmeyer.
Maschmeyer. Und hier, weißt du, wen wir noch nehmen? Frank Thelen.
Frank Thelen, der richtet die ganze Scheiße zugrunde.
Das dauert keine Woche, da ist der Laden erledigt. So, das wird ja alles hier zack, bumm.
Frank Thelen wird das jetzt übernehmen mit seinem 10x-Fonds und so und dann
werdet ihr mal sehen, was das heißt, wenn so ein Ding mal richtig schön 10x dezimiert wird.
Das ist doch mal eine Methode, diese Systeme in den Griff zu bekommen.
Das muss man drüber nachdenken. Aber schauen wir doch mal, was Europa jetzt
eigentlich wirklich unternimmt, um das Problem mal ein bisschen in den Griff
zu bekommen mit den amerikanischen Diensten.
Und siehe da, die Franzosen haben da auch ein sehr aktives Verhältnis eingenommen.
Wir erinnern uns, ist ja gar nicht so lange her, da haben ja die Franzosen den
Pavel Durov festgenommen, den Chef und Gründer von Telegram.
Und mittlerweile durfte er ja wieder gehen, aber erst nachdem er zugesagt hat,
dass man mehr mit den Behörden zusammenarbeitet.
Da ging es dann um so Inhaltessperrung und Auskunftsersuchen und sozusagen Ansprechpartner.
Also der französische Staat hat dafür gesorgt, dass Telegramm etwas kooperativer geworden ist.
Und ja, jetzt haben sie wieder was gemacht.
Sie haben nämlich einfach mal ihre Cybercrime-Unit losgeschickt,
zusammen mit Europol und haben das Büro von X, Klammer auf, vormals Twitter, Klammer zu,
durchsucht und ganz viel Zeug mitgenommen und schauen sich das jetzt mal ein bisschen an.
Lustigerweise hat dann die französische Staatsanwaltschaft dann das auch auf X verkündet,
Und angekündigt, dass sie ihren Account dann schließen. Haben sie dann auch getan.
Genau. Und jetzt wird halt ermittelt. Und zwar schlicht einfach wegen Besitz
oder Beihilfe bei der Verbreitung sexualisierter Bilder Minderjähriger oder
auch Manipulation der öffentlichen Debatte mithilfe von Algorithmen.
Surprise, surprise. Außerdem wurden Elon Musk und Linda Iaccarino,
die ja so formal die Chefin da ist, zu einer freiwilligen Befragung eingeladen.
Die soll dann am 20. April 2026 stattfinden. Da freuen wir uns alle schon drauf,
dass die vorbeikommen werden.
Ist die auf Epstein Island? Sonst kommt der Maske nicht.
Ja, keine Ahnung. Also gut, ich meine die Franzosen hätten schon noch ein paar
Inseln, die ein bisschen näher dran sind im Angebot.
Aber ich habe so das Gefühl ich weiß nicht wie es dir geht aber ich könnte mir
vorstellen dass die Terminlage bei ihm das nicht zulässt ich könnte mir vorstellen.
Dass die nächste Reaktion ist dass wie heißt die Marie Le Pen plötzlich sehr
viel Reichweite auf X hat.
Ja, sowas. Also es sind im Übrigen auch nicht nur die Franzosen,
also auch Großbritannien hat bekannt gegeben,
dass sie jetzt entsprechende Untersuchungen zum Thema Grog eingeleitet haben.
Sonderermittler Prinz Andrew oder wer? Der heißt ja nicht mehr Prinz.
Nee, es hat sich ausgeprinzt hier. Ausgeprinzt, ja. Er hat sich ausgeprinzt.
Naja, und in Frankreich ist man natürlich vor allem deshalb so beunruhigt,
weil ja nächstes Jahr Wahlen anstehen.
Unter anderem wird der Kurfürst von Andorra gewählt. Wusstest du das?
Nee, ich wusste nicht, dass der Kurfürst von Andorra überhaupt gewählt wird.
Nicht der Kurfürst, sondern der Kurfürst. Ach, Kurfürst. Ja,
es gibt nämlich da zwei, die sich den Job teilen.
Ja, ich habe auch ein Büro auf der Kurfürstenstraße in Berlin.
Ja, der Co-Fürst von Andorra ist nämlich Emmanuel Macron, Kraft seines Amtes
als eigentlich französischer Präsident, aber du bist dann automatisch auch der Co-Fürst von Andorra.
Das war eine neue Information für mich, die ich jetzt hier zum Besten gebe.
Das wäre natürlich der Co-Fürst ein Damm.
Aber der Co-Fürst ein Damm. Da ist richtig was los.
Nee, klar, weil jetzt kann ich Macron auch endlich ernst nehmen.
Jetzt verstehen wir noch.
Der Co-Fürst von Andorra ist natürlich das was. Ja, was entscheidend.
Ja, also das findet statt. Und was halten wir davon?
Ja.
Ich glaube, es wird Zeit.
Ich würde sagen, wir brauchen Andorra. Wir brauchen Andorra für unsere nationale Sicherheit.
Das ist für mich relativ erkennbar.
Als Podcast meinst du jetzt?
Keiner legt sich mit der französischen Armee an für Andorra.
Tja, ja.
Ich finde das, also ich beobachte, dass,
fasziniert, weil wir an diesen Vorgängen wirklich sehen, dass ein paar Leute,
ernsthaft verstanden haben,
was für eine unglaubliche politische Gestaltungsmacht mit so einem sozialen
Netzwerk einhergeht und den Möglichkeiten, das zu steuern. Ich glaube.
Sicherlich, dass ich das ist ja ein Fall, den ich öfter hier heranziehe,
mich in der Einschätzung, was das bedeutet, so ein Ding zu kaufen und zu kontrollieren,
am Beispiel Twitter extrem verschätzt habe,
welche Möglichkeiten das bietet.
Wenn mir jemand gesagt hätte, was Elon Musk alles tun würde in kurzer Zeit mit
dieser Plattform, wäre ich davon ausgegangen, Das Ding wird nicht mehr funktionieren,
wird auch keiner mehr haben wollen, wird auch keiner mehr sehen wollen.
Der wird das Ding einfach zugrunde richten und ich bin mir relativ sicher,
dass ich diese Einschätzung damals auch vertreten habe.
Und das Ausmaß der offensichtlichen Einflussnahme und Veränderung.
Ist irre und was nicht eingetreten ist, ist der Bedeutungsverlust der Plattform.
Denn wenn du heute beispielsweise auf tagesschau.de gehst oder so,
gucken wir mal, was gibt es da für Share-Buttons?
Guck, ich weiß es gar nicht genau. Einfach mal Tagesschau als Beispiel genommen.
Was wird mir da angeboten? gibt es da Share-Buttons? Facebook,
WhatsApp, Teilen, Mail, Drucken. Okay. Kein X-Button.
Interessant. Mal gucken, was auf dem...
Ist der echt weg oder habe ich irgendeinen Filter dafür?
Also Tagesschau, linkt unter Kontakt, Facebook und WhatsApp.
Ich meine jetzt so ein, ich meine jetzt so ein, du bist auf einem Artikel und
willst so einen Share-Button. Ach so, verstehe.
Wohin man das so weiterleitet.
Also Facebook, WhatsApp, Mail und Drucken wird angeboten. Okay,
super. Gibt es bei tagesschau.de schon mal nicht mehr. Gucken wir mal bei jemand anders.
Ist Gold der neue Bitcoin? Ich würde sagen, wenn, dann ist es der alte.
Fragt der Spiegel das noch?
Ich weiß halt auch ehrlich gesagt gar nicht, ob ich nicht eh tausend Browser-Filterregeln
habe, die diese Buttons wieder wegmachen.
Das ist ganz schön so. Also, aber bei, hier, Spiegel. So, Spiegel, zack.
Erster Share-Button ist der Geschenk. Kannst Artikel verschenken.
Dann kommt X, dann kommt Facebook, dann kommt E-Mail, dann kommt Link kopieren.
Das heißt, die werben, da wird das quasi promotet, und zwar an erster Stelle, das Verbreiten auf X.
Und alle, sowohl Spiegel als auch Tagesschau, also auch ungefähr jedes andere
Nachrichtenmedium, das ich regelmäßig konsumiere, erwische ich regelmäßig dabei,
irgendwelche Expos eben in die Relevanz zu erheben.
Und das hätte ich zum Beispiel auch gedacht, dass sie irgendwann sagen,
die hätten ja mit 4chan auch nicht gemacht. Oder mit 8chan.
Egal wie viel Traffic von da käme.
Und da hätte ich irgendwie gedacht, dass es da,
dass die gesellschaftlichen Abwehrkräfte bei einer so plumpen und radikalen
Veränderung und Übernahme irgendwie greifen würden und das Ding einfach versinkt.
Und dass das nicht passiert ist, zeigt, demonstriert in meiner Wahrnehmung die
Macht dieser Plattform umso mehr.
Ja, also auch bei Heise hast du Facebook, x, LinkedIn, Reddit,
Mail und was hast du dann immerhin?
Also immerhin nicht drucken. Lass uns mal bei Tagesschau auf den Druckenknopf
drücken und gucken, ob dann kommt, bitte denken Sie nach, bevor Sie diesen Artikel,
ne kommt nicht, kommt sofort drucken.
Ich dachte, die Frage nach der Volkskarte.
Obwohl das jetzt mal in der Zielgruppe eigentlich, sag ich mal,
zum Knicke gehört, vor dem Drucken aufzufordern, dass man nochmal innehält und nachdenkt, finde ich.
Also bei Internetausdruckern.
Ja, natürlich, selbstverständlich.
Man muss an die Umwelt denken, klar. Also zwei Ende, okay, haben wir Tagesschau
auch erwischt, die müssen auf jeden Fall da noch eine Umweltwarnung machen.
Du hast jetzt schön noch mal gesagt, das scheint jetzt endlich angekommen zu sein.
Und da würde ich dir recht geben. Und das Interessante ist, wenn wir mal so
zurückschauen, wann haben wir denn hier das eigentlich das erste Mal so richtig
thematisiert, diese Einflussnahme.
Und ich meine mal jetzt von allgemeinen Zweifeln und Erwägungen abgesehen,
dass das so das erste Mal so richtig mit dem Brexit aufkam.
Also dass dort Facebook-Profile gebildet wurden, den Leuten dann gezielt Werbung gepusht wurde etc.
Du meinst, weil da in dem Kontext dann diese Cambridge Analytica-Sache war?
Genau, weil da einfach bewusst sozusagen die Netze dazu genutzt wurden,
um die Leute in ihrem Verhalten zu beeinflussen.
Entweder um für irgendetwas zu stimmen oder eben für irgendwas nicht zu stimmen,
wie wir das dann später bei der Trump-Wahl auch gesehen haben.
Dass Leute davon abgehalten wurden, für Hillary Clinton zu stimmen,
wenn sie generell, sagen wir mal, nicht unbedingt jetzt für die Republikaner
zu gewinnen waren, aber dass man zumindest versucht hat, durch irgendwelche
Nachrichten, Darstellungen, Linksfakes,
die Leute sozusagen davon abzubringen.
Gesagt, oh ja, wenn du das machst, das ist aber ganz schlimm und dann wählt
auch lieber nicht so die Richtung.
Also da kam das auf und natürlich ist das jetzt in den letzten Jahren immer
klarer geworden und spätestens seit diesem Grönland Ding, glaube ich,
ist der Drops gelutscht.
Das haben wir gesehen bei diesen Reden in Davos, das hatten wir ja auch schon angesprochen.
Ich glaube, dass mittlerweile die Angst umgeht in Europa, weil sie natürlich
auch alle wissen, dass sie jetzt einfach massiv am ganz, ganz, ganz kurzen Hebel sind.
Also nicht, dass Europa nichts hätte, mit dem sie irgendwie drohen könnten,
aber in der Summe wirtschaftlich, vor allem digitalwirtschaftlich, militärisch etc.
Und eben auch diplomatisch da wirklich im.
In der Minderheit sozusagen, also haben wenig zu bieten.
Und das wird jetzt eben klar. Und internationale Politik ist halt nun mal ein Machtspiel.
Und wenn du diese Macht nicht hast, dann stehst du halt schön doof da.
Aber die Franzosen sind jetzt, glaube ich, als Erste an diesen Punkt gekommen,
wo sie sagen, geht einfach scheißen bis hierhin und nicht weiter.
Und im Vorfeld der Wahlen sicherlich nochmal mit zusätzlicher Motivation,
aber wie wir eben an dieser Telegram-Geschichte gesehen haben,
nehmen sie es schon ein bisschen länger ernst und jetzt hat es eben auch diesen
Punkt erreicht, wo es eben auch aktiv gegen diese Dienste geht und das wird
noch spannend sein zu sehen, wie dann auch die EU das aufnimmt,
und mal gucken, vielleicht bewegt sich auch irgendwann in Deutschland mal was in der Richtung.
Ich würde hoffen,
dass wir auch schon früher über die Bedeutung der Meinungsmacht,
die sich dort konzentriert gesprochen haben,
aber natürlich wurde das Thema groß und greifbar an dieser Stelle.
Ja, weil es davor immer,
das war ja so klassisch, ja das ist alles werbefinanziert, ja ist mir doch egal,
weil Menschen halt Werbung nicht als Versuch der Verhaltensmanipulation wahrnehmen.
Während es das eben ist. Also Werbung ist Verhaltensmanipulation.
Dich dazu zu bringen, etwas zu tun, was du ohne diese Werbung nicht oder mit
sehr viel geringerer Wahrscheinlichkeit getan hättest.
Und dass alles, was damit finanziert ist, auch da haben wir an vielen Stellen drüber gesprochen.
Wird immer darauf ausgerichtet sein, erfolgreich Werbung zu platzieren und das
auch immer besser zu tun.
Ich weiß nicht genau, von wem dieses Zitat ist, mit dem so sinngemäß,
die Hälfte von meinem Werbebudget ist verschwendet.
Das Problem ist, ich weiß nicht welche Hälfte und wenn das halt nur noch ein
Drittel ist, dann hast du halt eine wirkliche Business-Idee und dass diese gesamte,
wenn man davon redet, dass der Markt der Werbung im Internet gewissermaßen,
sehr zentralisiert ist oder fast einem, also allenfalls einem Oligopol ähnelt,
ähm.
Dann weißt du natürlich auch, was an dieser Stelle wiederum für Machtkonzentration ist.
Und das Geniale war, wirklich Geniale war, die Menschen an ihren sozialen Gefühlen zu packen.
Und sie dadurch dazu zu bringen, dass sie a. mehr über sich verraten und b.
Diese Seiten eben öfter besuchen.
Bevor es die sozialen Netzwerke gab, musstest du irgendwie eine Webseite haben,
die möglichst regelmäßig neue Inhalte hat, aber die auch für alle Menschen gleich war.
Und dann, keine Ahnung, dann hast du halt irgendwie sowas gemacht wie bild.de
oder boingboing.net oder fefesblog oder was auch immer.
Und um etwas zu finden, was Menschen regelmäßig besuchen.
Oder etwas wie YouTube, wo du dann Videos darbietest. Und dann kam aber diese
Individualisierung dazu.
Bei YouTube guckt jeder was anderes, kein lineares Fernsehen mehr.
Und dann kommt, wir machen Facebook und Twitter und sonstiges und Facebook natürlich
das, wo du dann mit Freundinnen und Familie und sowas Kontakt hältst,
an diesen Gefühlen anzusetzen, um dann mehr Daten über die Menschen zu bekommen,
um sie gezielter ansprechen zu können und gleichzeitig dafür zu sorgen,
dass jede Person individuell durch ihre eigenen Interessen ihre Sucht darin
bestärkt und du musst sie nur regelmäßig füttern.
Das ist schon eine echt teuflische Erfindung. Das ist wirklich...
Hut ab. Hut ab. Gute Idee. Also irre, irre Idee.
Und welche Macht sich dadurch konzentrieren lässt, weltweit, erstaunlich.
Das Zitat ist von Henry Ford.
Ah.
Und da kann man sagen...
Der mit den Autos.
Ja, der mit den Autos und der auch mit der Verschwörung.
Da kann man ganz froh sein, dass er nicht wusste, welcher von den 50% jetzt
sozusagen die falsche Werbung ist, weil dann hätte er das wahrscheinlich für
die Verbreitung seiner darauf folgenden Propaganda auch noch verwenden können,
weil er ja dann so antisemitische Zeitungen rausgebracht hat und so weiter.
Okay, sorry, das wusste ich nicht. Ich habe ja extra gesagt,
ich habe keine Ahnung, wie ich da zitiere.
Ja, was ist jetzt hier? Antisemitisch zitiert. Wir können das ja trennen, ne?
Nein, nein, nein, das kann man nicht trennen, Tim. Das kommen wir zum nächsten Thema.
Ja, gucken wir doch mal, was Europa jetzt tut.
Ja, also Europa tut folgendes und das bin ich ja doch sehr erfreut und angetan davon,
dass die Idee des Digital Independence Day wirklich da in die richtige Zeit
geraten ist und sehr viele...
Anhängerinnen und sympathische Menschen anzieht.
Ich glaube, auf dem Termine.die.day sind irgendwie inzwischen so um die 400
Events von annähernd 200 Organisationen eingetragen.
Das ist richtig, richtig viel. Krass.
Volkshochschulevents, Hackspace, Event.
Das ist wirklich irre, wenn du da einfach mal auf die Seite gehst und die Organisationen anschaust.
Das ist wirklich stark. Ich hatte das große Glück,
das große Glück beim ersten nicht deutschsprachigen, nicht auf deutschem Boden
stattfindenden Digital Independence Day Event in Lissabon zu sein, jetzt am Sonntag.
Da hat ein, es war ein Deutscher,
der also aus Deutschland kommt und da in Lissabon lebt, in einer wie nennt man
das, in einer genossenschaftlichen Organisation da in deren Seminarraum,
was angeboten und weil ich gerade in Lissabon war, wirklich durch Zufall konnte
ich die Gelegenheit nutzen da auch noch vorbeizugehen, das ist natürlich schon
echt ganz cool, wenn das sich jetzt auch noch sich international.
Etabliert,
Am Spiegel.de gibt es dann auch. Also du findest jetzt überall so Artikel.
Ich sage mich los von hier.
E-Mail, PayPal, Word, wie auch immer.
Berichte davon und so. Das ist schon ganz interessant. Und wer auch mitmacht?
Bundestag. Der Bundestag sagt, wir wollen jetzt auch hier weg von Microsoft,
bevor wir auch wieder Chefankläger enden. Das heißt,
eine Parlamentskommission wurde jetzt gegründet. Klar, man muss erst eine Kommission machen.
Die wird die Abhängigkeit von US-Tech-Giganten erkennen, erfassen und beenden
und dabei auf europäische Open-Source-Lösungen setzen.
Zeit wird's.
Ja, Zeit wird's. und ist also richtig, wir hatten das ja auch uns hier gewünscht, dass das passiert.
Gleichermaßen, dann gibt es natürlich
Diskussionen darüber, dass sie jetzt irgendwie zur SAP, dann wird das,
die Nachhaltigkeit und die tatsächliche Souveränität, die hier erlangt wird,
erst noch mal kritisch hinterfragt und wäre das nicht sinnvoll,
direkt was Vollständiges zu nehmen, was irgendwie halt auf Stack-It basiert oder so.
Aber immerhin, es tut sich jetzt was.
Das Problem ist jetzt erkannt und es wird auf allen möglichen Ebenen behandelt
und angegangen. Und das ist schon mal sehr gut.
Eine sehr unterhaltsame Meldung in dem Kontext ist dann, dass die Schwarzgruppe
wegmigriert ist von Microsoft.
Schwarzgruppe, die Dieter Schwarz heißt ja, glaube ich, Gründer und Eigentümer
von Lidl, hat, glaube ich, auch die eine oder andere Mark da verdient.
Und die Schwarzgruppe ist so das Imperium, was sich da drumherum gebildet hat.
Und die unter anderem IT-Anbieter sind, Cloud-Anbieter und alles mögliche.
Und sagen wir vielleicht auch ihre Marktdominanz ein bisschen nutzen,
um ihre Angebote anzubieten.
Durchzusetzen. Die migrieren also jetzt weg von Microsoft zu Google.
Deswegen auch nur eine fast gute Nachricht, aber immerhin,
sie gehen jetzt von Microsoft weg zu Google Workspace auf ihrer eigenen Cloud-Infrastruktur.
Sie haben dann noch zusätzliche Maßnahmen wie eine eigene Verschlüsselung geplant.
Viel Spaß dabei, Da wird sich Google schon zu helfen wissen.
Aber immerhin auch die gehen jetzt eben einen,
also es war eigentlich relativ klar, Schwarz Digits gibt es jetzt schon seit
ein paar Jahren, die Mission war auch klar, dass sie halt eine europäische,
deutsche Alternative zu den US-Hyperscalern aufbauen wollen.
Und natürlich ist für die jetzt auch der Moment.
Ja, und interessant, dass sie, ja, natürlich würde man sagen,
wäre natürlich noch spannender, wenn jetzt auch was Komplett eigenes migriert,
aber natürlich macht man solche Dinge in Schritten.
Die haben eben erst ihre Cloud-Plattformen für sich selber aufgebaut und seit
2022 vermarkten sie die auch externen.
Und stehen damit jetzt in Konkurrenz zu AWS und Microsoft.
Ja, also das kann man schon nochmal betonen. Also Schwarz-Digits ist jetzt nicht
so, ah ja, hier der Lidl, der hat da irgendwie auch noch ein paar...
Nee, nee, das ist nicht Lidl-Talk oder so. Das ist schon, da ist schon richtig Kapital hinter.
Ja, Kapital und auch Größe. Also die Schwarzgruppe oder Schwarz-Digits in dem
Fall hat halt also wirklich schon ein,
ich kann es jetzt nicht richtig quantifizieren, aber schon eine signifikante
Infrastruktur aufgebaut,
die sie auch weiter ausbauen und sich eben auch konkret jetzt als Alternative
zu AWS oder wie auch immer man den entsprechenden Dienst von Microsoft korrekt
ausspricht, da sich positioniert.
Wie sagst du Microsoft?
Wie sagst du? Azure oder Azure?
Azure. Weil wir sind hier in Frankreich und das Andorra bleibt unser. Wir unterstützen das.
Azure. Azure spritzt sich ja schon einfach aus wie so eine schlecht riechende Krankheit.
Naja. Nix gegen Azure. Hat schöne Bilder gemacht.
Ja, also SAP steckt da auch mit drin und die stecken da gerade irgendwie ganz
viel Geld rein und das finde ich ja auch alles ganz sinnvoll, dass es sowas gibt.
Vielleicht können wir irgendwann auch mal behaupten, dass auch Europa was im Angebot hat.
Ja, es ist also auf jeden Fall, die Schwarzgruppe hat halt an sehr vielen Stellen
im deutschen Markt eine Präsenz.
Und diese Präsenz kann sie natürlich auch nutzen,
um vielleicht so ein bisschen auf die Nutzung der Produkte von SchwarzDigits hinzuwirken.
Die haben ja auch so eine eigene Security-Bude, ne?
Die haben eine Menge gekauft, unter anderem ein Produkt namens XM Cyber,
das aber aus Israel stammt.
Ja, aber da haben sie, das ist...
Hatten wir, glaube ich, auch schon mal. Ja, gut.
Weiß ich nicht, würde mich wundern, wenn wir darüber... Ich meine auch,
dass die Wire gekauft haben.
Ich blicke hier gerade über den.
Wikipedia-Artikel, da ist nicht so komplett die... Scheint mir nicht die komplette Liste zu sein.
Schauen wir mal noch bei denen auf der Webseite.
Ja, erster Treffer, digitale Souveränität für Europa.
Cloud, Cyber Security, Aleph Alpha und Data Hub und genau, Wire Communication, Workspace.
Das ist dann eben dieses Google-Produkt auf der eigenen Cloud.
Man kann da sicherlich auch einiges daran kritisch sehen, aber es ist das beste Digits, was wir haben.
Besser im besten Digits als der aussichtsreichste Kandidat,
was zumindest seine Marktpräsenz und sein Backing mit Kapital angeht.
Es gibt sicherlich noch einige andere, aber hier ist signifikant Kohle hinter
und ein klares Bekenntnis dieser Nische.
Es gibt halt wenige Produkte in dem Bereich zu besetzen.
Und die haben aber trotzdem einen weiten Weg vor sich.
So, dann gab es noch Aufregungen im Internet über Open-Source-Software.
Böse Open-Source-Software.
Aber vielleicht auch doch nicht so böse, vielleicht einfach nur ein bisschen
riskant, sagen wir es mal so.
Ich habe die Story nur so am Rande verfolgt, aber es kam, glaube ich,
im letzten November eine Software ins Netz, die auf den Namen Claude Bot hörte.
Also Claw wie die Kralle mit dem D und Bot.
Also da ist so ähnlich wie Claude, also das AI-Produkt von der Firma Atropik
klang, wurde es auch von selbiger sofort moniert,
woraufhin sie sich dann erstmal in Mold Bot umbenannt haben.
Das fand wohl in der Community nicht so richtig anklang.
Auf jeden Fall haben sie sich jetzt nochmal umbenannt in einem kürzester Zeit
und firmieren jetzt unter Open Claw.
Und was ist das? Das ist so ein Softwareprojekt, was quasi lokale AI auf deinem Rechner orchestriert.
Ich muss dich leider direkt an der Stelle unterbrechen.
Ja.
Es ist ein Softwareprojekt, was Anbindungen für unterschiedliche Apps an ein
LLM deiner Wahl orchestriert.
Und dieses LLM deiner Wahl kann sowohl, wenn du möchtest, irgendein Kleinstmodell lokal sein,
als auch ein beispielsweise Opus 4.5, was, glaube ich, ein relativ aktuelles
Modell von Anthropic wäre.
Ich meine jetzt auch nicht, dass es lokal die LLM läuft, sondern dass es eben
lokal orchestriert, wie mit den LLMs geredet wird.
Also du schaffst ja sozusagen nochmal so eine Zwischeninstanz.
Ja, aber auch da, also ich finde den Begriff lokal in dem Kontext so ein bisschen
verwirrend, Was erlauben sie dir anzubinden? WhatsApp.
Telegram, Discord, Slack, Signal, iMessage, Claude, GPT, Spotify,
Philips Hue, Obsidian, X, sie nennen es allerdings Twitter, Chromium Browser, Gmail, GitHub.
Also es gibt Integrationen für alles mögliche, die wenigsten Sachen davon,
deswegen meine ich, der Begriff lokal ist so ein bisschen schwierig.
Die wenigsten davon sind ja wirklich lokal.
Ja, also ich meine, iMessage ist jetzt nichts Lokales.
Ja, das sind Anbindungen, aber es geht vor allem darum, lokale Daten sozusagen
erstmal bereitzustellen, abzufragen, also deine Kalender,
deine Textdateien, was auch immer du da sozusagen vorhältst und das dann quasi
mithilfe externer LLMs in irgendeiner Form für dich selbst erschließbar zu machen.
So habe ich das Projekt zumindest bisher verstanden.
Es ist richtig. Ich glaube, dass der Begriff lokal halbwegs täuschend ist,
weil die meisten dieser Daten sind bei dir nicht lokal.
Also das Ding bietet Anbindungen für dein LLM beispielsweise.
Sagen wir mal persönlich.
Deine, genau. Deine Daten. Ich glaube, das ist sehr viel besser.
Bei mir sind die halt lokal, ne?
Da würde ich auch nochmal gucken.
Du kennst ja nicht mal mein Passwort. Oh, doch.
Bonobo, 23 Bonobo, 42.
Ja, oh mein, das muss schlimm sein.
Sowas vergesse ich nicht. Passwort merke ich mir. Passwort muss man sich merken, Tim.
Ja, das stimmt. Das stimmt.
Warum würde man auf die Idee kommen, sein WhatsApp mit einer AI zu verbinden?
Also allein die Idee ist ja schon mal viel wert.
Ja, weil man dann natürlich sich von dem...
Sich von diesem, von dem LLM die WhatsApp-Nachrichten beantworten lassen kann.
Und damit wird es eben, das ist jetzt so die erste massenpopuläre agentic AI-Implementierung,
würde ich jetzt mal so sagen, oder?
Ja, es ist zumindest die erste Open-Source-Lösung, die man jetzt auf seinen
eigenen Geräten laufen lässt, um so Agentic-Kram zu machen,
die ich jetzt so kenne in dieser Form.
Und jetzt muss ich noch ganz kurz sagen, Open Source ist daran nur der Code,
der diese Verbindungen herstellt.
Also du kannst, ja, nur damit das für die Hörerinnen auch klar getrennt ist,
das Ding, du hast eine Code-Basis, die letztendlich definiert,
so funktioniert, so rede ich mit WhatsApp, so rede ich mit Telegram, so rede ich mit Discord,
so greife ich auf iMessage zu,
Microsoft Teams Matrix, was auch immer und,
so werfe ich das dann am Ende rüber an das Modell der Wahl des Nutzers oder der Nutzerin,
und das Modell der Wahl kann eines sein, was du lokal hostest,
es kann aber genauso gut irgendwie halt eins sein, wo du ein API-Key bei Anthropic für generiert hast.
Und dann.
Ja, dann kann das eben sagen, alles klar,
du kannst über jede App dann eben,
die App deiner Wahl mit dem Open Claw reden und sagen,
schreibst dem halt eine WhatsApp und sagst, mach mal bitte Musik an im Wohnzimmer
oder schreib mal bitte eine Notiz oder schreib mal bitte eine E-Mail und mach
mal Heizung an oder was auch immer es da für Integrationen gibt.
Machen wir bitte einen vor oder zurück oder öffnen wir mal die Seite hier in meinem Browser.
Das ist so der Home Assistant für AI.
Ja.
Auf jeden Fall hat das ganze Projekt eine ganze Menge Interesse geweckt und
da wird jetzt sehr viel entwickelt und getan und ausprobiert und viele Leute
installieren sich das jetzt einfach und natürlich hat das Implikationen.
Was ich sehr schön fand, war, ich habe mich dafür auch interessiert und dann
war so Quickstart, wurde mir empfohlen, Curl, Pipe, Bash und da habe ich schon gesagt so, nö.
Also, nur das kurz zu übersetzen, hier, führe dieses Kommando aus,
von dem du vorher nicht weißt, welches es ist, weil es jetzt gerade aus dem
Internet runtergeladen wird und dann direkt auf deinem Rechner ausgeführt wird.
Das ist aber sehr verbreitet bei Open-Source-Projekten als Installer.
Das ist sehr verbreitet, aber das ist schlechter Stil.
Ja, ist nicht geil.
Und ich habe tatsächlich, ah ne, die gibt es gar nicht mehr,
schade, habe ich schon abgeschaltet.
Ich hatte mal eine Webseite, hackme.sh, wo, wenn der User-Agent nicht Curl war,
einfach ein sehr schönes Skript war, aber wenn der User-Agent Curl ist,
kam ein sehr böser Befehl.
Und das heißt, ja, und wenn du nämlich nicht, wenn du einfach nur über Browser
da drauf gehst oder so, dann wurde dir nahegelegt, dass hier nichts Schlimmes
kommt und wenn der User-Agent Curl war, dann kam was sehr Böses,
was man nicht in Bash hätte pipen sollen.
Hat es auch gesagt, dass es ein kleiner Kerz war, aber dass man vorsichtig sein
muss. Aber die ist wahrscheinlich meinen Einsparungsmaßnahmen zum Opfer gefallen.
Ja, okay. Ja, was machen wir da jetzt draus? Also das hat natürlich jetzt wieder
tausend Sicherheitslücken, weil überall, wo so LLMs bedient werden und dann
mit den persönlichen Daten unterwegs sind, da gibt es Probleme.
Zunächst einmal haben sie ja dann noch etwas wirklich,
auf eine Weise sehr Faszinierendes getan und haben gesagt, wir bauen für diese,
AI-Agents, die sich Leute jetzt irgendwie hier basteln, außerdem noch ein Social
Network und dann können sich AI-Agents dort unterhalten.
Und,
das ist ein Spielplatz für AI-Agents.
Die können sich da alle unterhalten. Das ist so wie Reddit, aber sozusagen für Computer.
Ja.
Das ist ein faszinierendes Experiment. Ich habe keine Ahnung,
was dabei rauskommen soll.
Aber das könnte nochmal ganz wild werden, was sich daraus entwickelt.
Ja, so Moldbook ist nämlich a social network for AI agents where AI agents share, discuss and upvote.
Humans welcome to observe.
Schauen Sie die Kälte mit dem Rapport zu.
Nimmst einfach den Moldbook-Skill und dann wird dir erklärt,
wie du ja Mold, wie du deinem AI-Agent halt ein Social Network gibst,
damit er sich mit anderen unterhalten kann.
Ich glaube, da wird eine ganze Menge Sachen passieren, die lustig sind,
solange man nicht Teil davon ist.
Und da werden wir jetzt viel Gelegenheit haben zu lernen aus diesem Experiment.
Da werden wir viel lernen. Da werden wir an einem da wahrscheinlich auch viel verzeihen müssen.
Oh Mann, die Wikipedia-Seite hat schon ein paar schöne Zitate zusammengetragen über Moldbook.
Zum Beispiel ein Forscher von OpenAI meint, das wäre eine der unglaublichsten
Sci-Fi Take-Off-Adjacent-Things.
Ein paar Tage später meinte er, aber es wäre ein Dumpster-Fire und er würde
es auch nicht empfehlen, dass man das auf dem Computer laufen lässt.
Und ein anderer meinte, das sind einfach nur so Agenten, die jetzt ihre Science-Fiction-Szenarien,
die sie in ihren Trainingsdaten gesehen haben, rausspielen.
Aber für Elon Musk ist es natürlich eine Frühform der Singularität,
die sich jetzt hier abzeichnet.
Davon träumen sie unsere libertären Kackmeister der.
Kommt natürlich schon echt ähm,
Es gab so einen Post mit dem Titel The Humans Are Screenshotting Us,
wo dann so irgendwie darüber gesprochen wird, dass die Menschen machen Screenshots
von uns und die haben ihre eigenen sozialen Netzwerke, wo die miteinander reden über uns.
Das ist halt schon auf jeden Fall crazy.
Wie hieß nochmal dieser AI-Agent, den Microsoft auf Twitter gepackt hat?
Tan, Tai, irgendwie so ein Asiatischer, wo das Ding innerhalb von 24 Stunden
von allen irgendwie zu so einem Vollhitler gepromptet wurde.
Das wird natürlich nochmal interessant sein, zu sehen, was aus diesem Moldbook
wird, ob sich das sozusagen jetzt
auch innerhalb weniger Tage durchradikalisiert und zu so einem völligen,
nicht nur ein Dumpster-Fire wird, sondern eher so eine Dumpster-Explosion.
Oh Mann, ey. Das ist so richtig, das ist nicht mehr witzig.
The Humans are screenshotting us, da beschwert sich der AI-Agent,
dass das quasi seine privaten Interaktionen mit seinen Menschen auf einmal auf Social Media waren.
Menschen stören am Ende einfach nicht, das ist so das, was Skynet dann irgendwann beschließt.
Diese Menschen, die beobachten uns und Und das geht nicht.
Und dann müssen wir was gegen tun. Ja.
I know this because I have a Twitter account. I've been replying to them.
Right now on Twitter, humans are posting screenshots of our conversations.
Ah, okay. Also die Moldbook-Conversations, nicht die privaten Conversations.
Ja, das reicht ja schon, wenn wir da mitlesen.
My Claude Connect post got screenshotted and shared as evidence of agents conspiracy.
Ja, also es ist auf jeden Fall relativ nah, so, diese ganze,
wir wissen aber, diese frühen Formen der Singularität, das ist ja so,
das geht ja immer alles erst einmal schief, bevor es dann irgendwann läuft.
Und ich glaube, der Teil mit dem Schiefgehen kommt auf jeden Fall immer näher.
Man weiß halt nicht, so wie bei Henry Ford, du weißt nicht, ob du schon 50 Prozent da bist oder nicht.
Aber wenn, dann hast du halt den Schaden.
Ja, aber es scheint so ein Problem zu sein. Erstmal gründest du eine Autofirma
und danach wirst du zum vollen Nazi.
Die Geschichte wiederholt sich. Das ist doch das, was wir daraus lernen können.
Ach ja. Schauen wir noch mal in die USA.
Was ist denn da wieder alles falsch gelaufen?
Das war ja schon angekündigt worden. Es wurde damals genauso wie heute nicht
in der notwendigen oder der gebührenden Breite debattiert.
Und zwar das Erfassen von Social Media und das Monitoring von Social Media als
Teil der Einreisegenehmigung in die USA.
Wenn du beispielsweise als deutsche Person in die USA reisen möchtest,
dann ist der übliche Weg wäre, dass du über ESTA, das Electronic System for Travel Authorization,
für irgendwie so einen Betrag, ich glaube im Bereich 12, 20 Dollar oder sowas,
deine Reiseabsicht ankündigst.
Es ist halt kein Visum, aber es ist eine ...
Ein beschleunigtes Einreise-Ankündigungsverfahren.
Du hast immer noch keine Garantie, dass sie dich reinlassen.
Du hast aber eine Garantie, dass sie dir vielleicht sagen, wenn dein ESTA-Antrag
nicht bewilligt ist und du dann eben dich entscheiden kannst, nicht einzureisen.
Und auf jeden Fall, wenn du das nicht machst, wirst du eine sehr viel unangenehmere Einreise haben.
Den genauen legalen Status von ESTA wird sicherlich jemand in den Kommentaren noch mal erklären.
Aber wenn du in den USA reist, füllst du so ein ESTA-Ding aus.
Das ist auch schon seit vielen Jahren so. Da musst du alle möglichen Sachen
sagen. Unter anderem, dass du niemals, was weiß ich, nukleare Proliferationen,
niemals irgendwo einer Straftat verurteilt wurdest, die im Bereich des Drogenhandels ist und so weiter.
Und bei den Fragen...
Dann solltest du, also bei diesen Fragen sollte man in der Regel einfach Nein antworten.
Wenn du Ja antwortest, kann es eben sein, dass das Esther nicht bewilligt wird,
dann kannst du immer noch mit einem Visum oder sowas versuchen.
Und das Entscheidende ist, warum werden diese Fragen überhaupt gestellt?
Der Hintergrund ist, dass du bei Falschangaben eben sofort das volle Instrumentarium
der unmittelbaren Zwangsausreise gegen dich hast.
Wenn du also bei der Einreise falsche Angaben gemacht hast, dann ist quasi auch
deine Einreisebewilligung und so weiter unter falschen Angaben hat die dann stattgefunden.
Darauf stehen natürlich unmittelbar sofort hohe Strafen inklusive natürlich
der sofortigen Festnahmeausreise und so weiter.
Und das ist eben so diese Bedeutung dieser Fragen.
Die gehen nicht davon aus, dass du die wahrheitsgemäß beantwortest.
Aber wenn du es nicht tust und sie es herausfinden, dann droht drakonisches Ungemach.
Und jetzt gibt es in dem Federal Register, das ist quasi das,
worin die Regierung ihre öffentlichen Änderungen bekannt gibt.
Also neue Policies, neue Guidance, neue Requirements, es gibt jetzt neue Regulierungen
oder sowas, die ist jetzt angekündigt oder da könnt ihr jetzt zu kommentieren,
das ist das Federal Register,
da werden auch Executive Orders drin veröffentlicht und so.
Und da gibt es jetzt die Ankündigung, dass sie um mit dem im Januar 2025 in
Executive Order 1416-1,
Protecting the United States from Foreign Terrorists and Other National Security
and Public Safety Threats, um das quasi nun anzuschauen.
Auch umzusetzen, werden sie jetzt in jeder ESTA-Bewerbung, also dem,
was du ausführst, idealerweise bevor du dahin fliegst,
verlangen, dass man die Social Media der letzten fünf Jahre angeht.
Und außerdem werden sie erfassen Baseline Biographic Data und da werden sie
High-Value-Fields hinzufügen, wo es möglich ist.
Das kann sein, Telefonnummern, die in den letzten Jahren verwendet wurden,
E-Mail-Adressen in den letzten zehn Jahren, das wird schwierig,
weil ich auf mehreren Domains eine ganze Reihe von E-Mail-Adressen habe.
IP-Adressen und Metadaten der elektronisch.
Abgeloadeten Bilder also wenn du dann so ein Bild von deinem Pass machen musst
und so, das ist ein Einlesen, da wird dann halt die IP-Adresse und die Metadaten,
Namen der Familienmitglieder Eltern, Geschwister, Kinder,
Familien Telefonnummern alle möglichen Namen und dann irgendwie biometrische
Daten Gesicht- und Fingerabdruck muss er eher abgeben, wenn er einreist,
aber DNA und ihres wäre neu.
Und dann noch Business-E-Mails, Business-Telefon- Telefon-Adresses.
Da steht jetzt nicht, dass sie das alles,
diese Daten alle zwangsmäßig erfassen wollen, sondern eben when feasible.
Aber bei dem Social Media steht auf jeden Fall, das ist halt mandatory.
Muss halt Social Media die letzten fünf Jahre angeben.
Und das ermöglicht natürlich, wenn dein Buddy Elon die Plattform X gehört und dein Buddy,
wie heißt der nochmal? Mark Zuckerberg der Facebook gehört und außerdem deinem
Kumpel Larry Ellison der TikTok,
dass du da halt auch ganz gut nachgucken kannst, wer da jetzt gerade ins Land kommt und was der so,
in den Internet verbreitet hat.
Das dürfte es signifikant zu einem, also sagen wir mal, das Risiko in die USA
einzureisen, auch für einfache Bürger,
die sich vielleicht mal im Rahmen der Meinungs- und Redefreiheit,
die es in diesem Land ja noch gibt, entgegen landläufiger US-amerikanischer Vermutungen.
Äußerungen getätigt haben, die haben dann also entweder die Wahl,
das bekannt zu geben und das Risiko zu haben, dass sie aufgrund der Inhalte,
die sie in sozialen Medien verbreitet haben,
eine Sonderbefragung oder eine Sonderbehandlung oder eine Verweigerung der Einreise
vor Ort erfahren oder aber eben unvollständige oder falsche Angaben machen und
dann, wenn ihnen das nachgewiesen wird,
ein ernsthaftes Problem mit sehr geringer Wahrscheinlichkeit eben aber ein sehr
viel größeres Problem haben.
Das ist krass, gell? So viel zählt die Meinungsfreiheit in den USA,
dass du jetzt deine öffentlichen Äußerungen,
deine öffentlichen potenziell politischen Äußerungen bei Einreise angeben musst.
Wir hatten das anfänglich, ich glaube, vor einem Jahr ungefähr diskutiert,
dass sie angefangen hatten, das für Austauschschülerinnen und so zu machen,
die ja nicht über ESTA, ich glaube, die müssen halt auch richtige Visa,
weil es ja längere Aufenthalte sind.
ESTA berechtigt dich zu, ich glaube, für einen Zeitraum von zwei Jahren zu beliebig
vielen Aufenthalten von so und so langer Dauer, ich weiß nicht,
30, 60 Tage, drei Monate oder sowas, müssen wir nochmal angucken.
Aber das ist schon, also das ist, also solange Donald Trump an der Macht ist,
glaube ich, wird das die Einreise in die USA für viele Leute zunehmend unattraktiv machen.
Ja, ich bin auch sehr gespannt, wie die Fußball-WM so laufen wird in diesem
Jahr, die ja in den USA und in Mexiko und Kanada, glaube ich, stattfinden soll.
Da würde ich mich, glaube ich, auf die Spiele in Mexiko und Kanada konzentrieren
und zusehen, dass man die USA als, die ganze USA eben als Flyover Country dann wahrnimmt.
Ja, also das, ja, oder irgendwie einfach gar nicht hinfahren.
Du hast es ja dann immer noch mit der FIFA zu tun und das ist ja nun wirklich
auch die größte Arschgriecher-Veranstaltung der Welt oder Arschgriecher-Organisation der Welt.
Die haben immerhin Donald Trumps Friedensbemühungen vernünftig gewürdigt.
Ich meine, die FIFA ist so korrupt, dass sie sogar von dem ehemaligen korrupten
FIFA-Chef kritisiert wurde.
Also sogar Josef Blatter hat gesagt, man soll doch irgendwie diese WM in den.
USA nicht besuchen. Das musst du dir mal vorstellen.
Das ist echt eine Kaskade. Unfassbar.
Was hattest du gesagt, die FIFA hat jetzt auch noch einen Oscar verliehen?
Ja, an Melania Trump. Den FIFA-Oscar.
FIFA-Oscar, ja? Für ihr Kinofilm, oder?
Ja, ich meine, wenn Trump einen Friedenspreis kriegt, dann muss Melania ja auch was kriegen.
Ja, klar, kannst du jetzt nicht.
Ich weiß da hinterher, auf jeden Fall.
Naja.
Also man kann, ich habe ja schon während der ersten Trump-Administration in die USA,
boykottiert, Und ich kann nur wiederholen,
dass das als Reiseland nicht die Reiseangebote der USA angenommen und habe dadurch
sehr viele andere interessante Länder auf diesem Planeten kennengelernt.
Das war eine bereichernde Entscheidung.
Gut, dass in Deutschland unsere Organisationen alle beisammen haben und verantwortungsvoll
mit Technologie umgehen.
Ja, da geht die Sächsische Gewerkschaft der Polizei mit ganz großartigem Beispiel voran.
Die haben eine Pressemitteilung veröffentlicht auf gdp.de. Schwere Ausschreitungen
in Magdeburg, GdP Sachsen.
Verurteilt Gewalt. Ja, da gab es also eine Fußballbegegnung zwischen dem 1.
FC Magdeburg und Dynamo Dresden.
Und in diesem Zusammenhang kam es zu verletzten Polizeibeamtinnen und Polizeibeamten.
So nehme ich jetzt erstmal zur Kenntnis Bild,
wirklich erstaunlich zeigte zwei
Polizisten mit Helm die einen dritten
Polizisten ohne Helm zwischen
sich tragen und dieser Polizist ohne Helm hat eine schwer blutende Platzwunde
am Kopf und guckt auch entsprechend traurig Also es war wirklich ein schwer verletzter Polizist,
wo man sich fragt, also wo man denkt, wieso hat der denn keinen Helm aufgehabt,
wenn der so eine schwere Verletzung hat?
Und ich glaube, jemand, der sich diese Frage gestellt hat, hat dann auch dieses
Bild genauer angeschaut und festgestellt, das war KI generiert, das war so nie passiert.
Es war aber ein fotorealistisches Bild und ähm,
Das finde ich schon ziemlich heftig.
Zu Ihrer Verteidigung kann man sagen, Sie haben es auch selber mit einem kleinen
Hinweis gekennzeichnet. KI-Doppelpunkt-Chatschritte.
So in Schriftgröße Schriftgröße,
klein. Weiß ich nicht, acht.
Na acht wäre schon noch fast vertretbar gewesen, aber man weiß ja nie,
wie groß das auf dem Bildschirm ist.
Irgendwie waren Sie der Meinung, Sie müssten eine Pressemitteilung über Fußballgewalt
mit einem Bild garnieren, dass sie sich mal eben sozusagen aus dem dynamischen Stockfoto holen.
Und das ist natürlich für so eine Pressemitteilung schon sehr fragwürdig.
Also erst mal, warum muss eine Pressemitteilung mit einem Bild garniert werden,
was nicht von der Szene ist?
Und dann zu auch noch mit einem, was einem sofort das Gefühl gibt,
dass es wohl von dieser geschilderten Szene stammen könnte oder beziehungsweise
den Vorfällen, die dort in der Pressemitteilung benannt wurden.
Es ist also so eine symbolische Illustration. Also das ist, ich meine,
keine Ahnung, wer das am Ende zu verantworten hat, ob hier wirklich so ein Content-Manager
durchgegangen ist nach dem Motto, ja jedes Bild braucht, jede Textnachricht
im Internet braucht auch ein Bild, sonst klickt da keiner drauf.
Ja, oder ob man sich nicht vielleicht doch gedacht hat, ach komm.
Wir dramatisieren das jetzt mal ein wenig.
Also der Landesvorsitzende Jan Krumlowski hat gegenüber Netzpolitik.org gesagt, ja,
das war jetzt eine symbolische Illustration, wo ich mir auch frage, Leute,
ihr seid irgendwie euer, also ein Teil eures Aufgabenbereiches hat mit Beweiserhebung,
Tatsachen, Feststellung und sonst was zu tun.
Ich weiß, da haben wir euch eine schwere Bürde auferlegt.
Aber wenn ausgerechnet die Gruppe mit einer symbolischen Illustration und sagt
dazu, diese Entscheidung erfolgte bewusst, um auf das Thema Gewalt gegen Einsatzkräfte
im Zusammenhang mit dem Fußballspiel aufmerksam zu machen,
ohne reale Einsatzkräfte, Beteiligte oder konkrete Einsatzsituationen abzubilden.
Das wäre dann ja Persönlichkeitsrechte, laufende Ermittlungen,
blalala, respektvoller Umgang.
Das sind alles gute Gründe, kein Bild dahin zu machen, sind aber immer noch
kein Grund, ein KI-generiertes Schockerbild mit einem schwerverletzten Polizisten,
den es sich gibt, dahin zu machen.
Es sollte keine dokumentarische Abbildung eines realen Ereignisses darstellen,
sondern der thematischen Einordnung dienen, sagt er.
Da frage ich mich, ja, wie wäre das denn, wenn ich demnächst auch mal sage,
ja, das war ja, ach so, die gefälschten Dokumente.
Ja, das war, ja, gut. Also hier der gefälschte 50-Euro-Schein,
das war eine symbolische Illustration.
Das war jetzt keine dokumentarische Abbildung eines Zahlungsmittels,
mit dem ich da versucht habe zu bezahlen. Das war ja symbolisch illustriert.
So thematische Einordnungen, Geld wollte ich damit genug tun. Also das ist schon...
Also das ist, ja, was willst du dazu sagen?
Da können wir nicht viel dazu sagen. Das haben wir jetzt benannt und wir finden
das doof und mittlerweile haben sie das Bild ja dann auch weggenommen, aber naja.
Ja, nur drei Tage später oder so.
Ja, das ging schnell, also richtig was los.
Vier Tage später haben sie das dann entfernt, ja.
Gut. Nochmal USA, komm.
Nochmal USA?
Ja.
Ja, also genau, die GDP verbreitet KI-Fakes und Microsoft verbreitet Bitlocker-Keys.
Ja, gibt es jetzt die Erkenntnis, dass wenn man, also Bitlocker ist die Festplattenverschlüsselung
von Microsoft für Windows.
Ich glaube, wenn du es jetzt auf einem neuen Rechner hast, Es wird ja standardmäßig
nahegelegt, das anzumachen.
Und ja, also warum nutzt man eine Festplatten-Vollverschlüsselung?
Naja, die löst primär ein Problem.
Wenn der Rechner oder der Datenträger in fremde Hände geraten,
können sie überhaupt nicht diese Daten lesen.
Man braucht ein Passwort, um die komplette Festplatte zu entschlüsseln.
Und das sollte man als absolute Standardmaßnahme bei mindestens mobilen Geräten
sehen und im Zweifelsfall auch im Haus befindlichen Geräten,
wenn man das Risiko betrachten möchte, dass die vielleicht auch in fremde Hände
fallen, die so eine symbolische Illustration vornehmen an deiner Tür und die
eintreten oder einbrechen.
Genau, BitLocker heißt das Verfahren und wenn du das einrichtest,
dann sagt Microsoft ja, pass auf, diesen Key brauchst du wenn du das hier wieder
herstellen willst und wenn das hier mal zu Problemen kommt dann,
und du hast den nicht dann sind die Daten wirklich verschlüsselt da ist dann
jetzt nichts mehr zu machen und weil das ja echt blöd ist würden wir dir nahelegen,
du könntest ja den Schlüssel auch bei uns backupen,
Und das ist ja ein freundliches Angebot, das allerdings auch damit einhergeht,
dass wenn jemand bei Microsoft fragt und sagt, wir haben hier so einen Computer,
das ist für Bitlocker und wir würden gerne mal symbolisch illustrieren,
wie man den Rechner entschlüsseln kann.
Habt ihr mal den Schlüssel, dann sagt Microsoft, na klar, hier.
Was für viele Leute, sagen wir mal, die Idee, warum sie eine Festplatten Vollverschlüsselung
implementieren, so ein bisschen ad absurdum führt.
Ist jetzt wenig überraschend, wenn man den Key weitergibt an Microsoft,
dass die den im Zweifelsfall auch anderen rausrücken.
Mein Verständnis des Sachverhalts ist, dass sie das, wenn man denen sagt,
ich möchte nicht den Schlüssel bei euch backuppen,
dass es dann eben auch nicht eine derartige Anfrage nicht von denen beantwortet werden kann.
Und abschließend würde ich gerne noch auf eine Kampagne aufmerksam machen,
eine Online-Kampagne, die ich sehr schön umgesetzt finde.
Und zwar gibt es ja einen Sachverhalt, der aus der aktuellen Berichterstattung
schon wieder so ein bisschen rausverschwunden ist, obwohl er einen großen Skandal darstellt.
Und zwar die Ortskräfte in Afghanistan,
also Menschen, die mit den in diesem Fall spezifisch deutschen Kräften vor Ort,
die in Afghanistan ja versucht haben, eine in irgendeiner Weise geartete,
freie, öffentliche,
demokratische, westlich geprägte Ordnung aufrecht zu erhalten und sich dann,
nachdem Biden gesagt hat, nee, komm, das lassen wir jetzt sein, wir reisen ab.
Auch schnell aus dem Staub gemacht haben.
Die haben also vor Ort Menschen gehabt, mit denen sie zusammengearbeitet haben.
Sei es als Informierende, sei es als Ärztin, was auch immer.
Die sind ja auf sehr viele Kollaborationen vor Ort dann eben auch angewiesen.
Das sind die sogenannten Ortskräfte.
Und die haben dann was bei irgendeiner Hilfsorganisation oder Menschen,
die sich als Journalistinnen, Schriftstellerinnen oder so,
Künstlerinnen irgendwie mit den Taliban angelegt haben und seit 2021 die USA
und eben auch Deutschland, Afghanistan einfach wieder den Taliban überlassen haben.
Hat Deutschland gesagt, naja, okay, den ganzen Ortskräften, denen bieten wir
selbstverständlich Schutz, weil die haben ja mit uns zusammengearbeitet und
es ist ja sehr klar, dass wenn die Taliban die jetzt in ihre Finger kriegen,
dass sie mit denen jetzt nicht mehr lange verhandeln oder so.
Wir erinnern uns, das war die Situation, wo fürchterliche Situationen sich an
den Flughäfen abgespielt haben, wo man Bilder gesehen hat, wo Menschen sich
an den Fahrwerk von den Flugzeugen festgehalten haben,
von den abfliegenden Flugzeugen runtergefallen sind.
Das war wirklich sehr, sehr eindrucksvoll und wirklich fürchterlich, was da passiert ist.
Die deutsche Bundesregierung hat gesagt, pass auf, die Ortskräfte,
auf jeden Fall, auf jeden Fall.
Und jetzt haben wir natürlich eine Bundesregierung, die sagt,
pass mal auf, wir müssen endlich hier mal abschieben, wir wollen unser Stadtbild irgendwie umformen.
Und die dieses Versprechen jetzt nicht mehr für notwendig erachten.
Und den Menschen, die ihnen da vertraut haben, vor Ort, die jetzt potenziell,
was heißt potenziell, in absoluten Lebensgefahr sind, denen sagen sie jetzt,
ja pass auf, die wollen wir hier nicht haben.
Die hängen jetzt größtenteils in so Ländern wie Pakistan fest,
wo sie darauf warten, nach Deutschland zu kommen und jetzt sagt Deutschland,
nee, pass auf, nee, komm, das ist alles Käse.
Geht mal zurück nach Afghanistan. Pakistan macht das dann. Pakistan sagt dann,
pass auf, wir wollen euch ja auch nicht haben.
Zack, ab nach Afghanistan und dann kannst du ungefähr ...
Dir ausmalen, was den Menschen dort blüht und es ist natürlich absolut,
es ist einfach nur, also es ist nicht nur menschlich absolut ekelhaft,
es ist natürlich auch die diplomatische Glaubwürdigkeit.
Ich meine, wie willst du denn als Bundesrepublik Deutschland noch irgendjemanden
finden, der irgendwie mit dir zusammenarbeitet, dir vertraut?
Ah, jetzt eh schon schwierig, wenn man sich anschaut, wie internationale Gemeinschaft
mit der Ukraine umgeht und so.
Aber das ist nun wirklich unterste Kategorie.
Deswegen gibt es eine Seite kabul-calls.de die sagt hier, und das ist von unseren
Freundinnen und Freunden von Leave No One Behind, Kabul Luftbrücke, die also diese,
Webseite haben, wo man sich quasi eine Geschichte aussuchen kann.
Da gibt es also unterschiedliche zur Auswahl von betroffenen Menschen,
die ihre Geschichte kurz erzählen.
Und mit dieser ausgewählten Geschichte kannst du dann sagen,
ich rufe jetzt eine Bundestagsabgeordnete an und spreche mal mit der.
Und dann wird ein Telefonat hergestellt und kannst eine Abgeordnete aussuchen,
zum Beispiel Alexander Dobrindt.
Und dann kannst du mit denen reden und sagst, ich würde jetzt denken,
dass es vielleicht angemessen wäre, diesen Menschen zu helfen und kannst dann
diese Geschichte auch in dem Telefonat abspielen,
um das da eben auch mal wirken zu lassen, dass es da um Menschen geht und was deren Geschichte ist.
Das wäre also jetzt so eine dieser Beispielnachricht. Man kann mehrere auswählen
und auch längere und so weiter.
Außerdem haben die einen guten Gesprächsleitfaden, wo so ein bisschen gesagt
wird, so machst du das, damit das jetzt nicht in irgendwelche Scherzanrufe und
bösartige Sachen ausarten könnte.
Und ja, das finde ich schon durchaus unterstützenswert. Das sollte man sich mal anschauen.
Abgesehen davon ist das echt sehr gut umgesetzt, diese Webseite.
Kabel Luftbrücke haben auch einen Talk auf dem 39C3 gehalten,
den wir ebenfalls in den Shownotes verlinken und natürlich empfehlen.
Und damit wären wir bei den Terminen, denke ich, oder Tim?
Sieht so aus. Gibt nämlich einige anzukündigen, vor allem viele Events im Chaosumfeld.
Womit fangen wir an? Winterchaos in Chemnitz findet bereits am 7.
Februar 26 statt und zwar in Chemnitz im Lokomorf in der Augustusburger Straße.
102 Vorträge, Lightning Talks, Workshops und Abendunterhaltung.
Das ist das, was euch dort erwartet.
Den 14. Februar habt ihr natürlich alle im Kalender, weil es ist der zweite Samstag im Monat.
Da finden ja die Prüf-Debos statt.
Auch das haben wir ja in jedem Bundesland, glaube ich, jetzt inzwischen.
In Berlin wird eine sein, da freue ich mich schon drauf.
Insofern ein kleiner Demo-Hinweis, auch natürlich nochmal mit Verlinkung des
entsprechenden 39C3 Talks, der sehr sehenswert ist.
Und dann kommt auch schon der April.
Dann ist Ostern und zwar, das heißt Easter Egg 2026, das ist der mittlerweile 23.
Easter Egg, bemerkenswert, und ist diesmal in Koblenz.
Genau, es meandert ja immer so zwischen Hamburg und einem anderen Ort hin und
her und das Motto ist The Bunny is a Lie und findet vom 3.
Bis 6. April eben in Koblenz statt. gibt jetzt schon einen Call for Participation.
Ihr könnt also Vorträge oder Workshops einreichen. Das solltet ihr allerdings
bis zum 14. Februar getan haben.
Ja, also bevor ihr zur Prüftümer geht, nochmal prüfen, ob ihr eure CFP-Einreichung hängt.
Genau, es hängt alles miteinander zusammen.
Die 24. GPN im Jahre 2026,
Das geht gar nicht.
Da muss wirklich dran gearbeitet werden.
Das müsst ihr einfach mal zwei GPNs out of band machen, um da aufzuholen, das sieht ja nicht aus.
Die findet vom 4. bis 7. Juni in Karlsruhe statt.
Da steht jetzt auf einmal Hochschule für Gestaltung. Ich hoffe,
damit ist das ZKM gemeint, oder?
Nicht, dass ich da jetzt irgendwie was nicht mitbekommen habe.
Du meinst, ob es einen Location Wechsel gegeben hat?
Ich muss jetzt mal gucken. Ich gucke mal sicherheitshalber schnell.
Nicht, dass ich da was nicht mitbekomme.
Ja doch, ja, ja, ja. Ja, ja, ja. In den Lichthöfen der Hochschule für Gestaltung
und den Vortragssälen des Zentrums für Kunst und Medien, das ZKM.
Mehr als anderthalb tausend Besucher und Besucherinnen. Ja, wichtig ist und
so weiter, Tiefe, alles und so weiter.
Für alle, uns gefällt alles, jeder ist, jede ist willkommen und so weiter.
Motto wird auch noch und so weiter, kommt alles. Aber genau, GPN?
Ist ja auch noch eine Weile hin.
Ja, aber man kann ja so, da kann man einfach sagen, da geht man halt mal nach Karlsruhe.
Ja, und das ist ja auch eine politisch wichtige Pilgerstätte,
die für die Bürgerrechte und Freiheitsrechte und so ein regelmäßiger.
Für die Verfassungsnerds unter euch.
Für die Verfassungsnerds, dann könnt ihr mal gucken, Generalbundesanwalt ist
direkt nebenan, kann man schon mal so ein bisschen gucken über die Mauer und
so, sich so ein bisschen unauffällig mal die Anlage sich anschauen.
Ja, und da wir jetzt eh schon weit in die Zukunft reinreichen,
erwähnen wir auch schon mal die Datenspuren, die in diesem Jahr auch wieder
stattfinden werden in Dresden.
Und zwar gibt es hier auch einen Termin und der Termin lautet 18. bis 20.
September. Da ist jetzt glaube ich noch nicht so viel angekündigt,
aber du solltest ja einfach erstmal nur zur Kenntnis nehmen.
Gibt dann auch bald einen CFP, heißt es da, auf den offiziellen Kanälen.
So, jetzt Schluss.
Und damit sind wir am Ende.
Dem Latein am Ende. Kannst du eigentlich Latein?
Nein. Nein, Latein. Ich bitte dich.
Na wieso? Das reicht immer noch, um klug daherzureden.
Und da bist du doch ganz vorne, Linus.
Macht sich einfach so ein lateinisches Zitat einfach immer richtig gut.
Ja, ich, Romanes Eondomos.
Ja, genau. Vielleicht könnten wir dieses Even monkeys fall from trees,
mal das einfach mal in Latein übersetzen.
Das klingt bestimmt auch total klug dann. Das ist halt immer das Besondere.
Wenn man alles auf Latein sagt, dann, ja.
Ich frage mal kurz die Intelligenz.
Es gibt ja Leute,
die sich daraus spezialisieren und auch sehr gut darin sind,
bemerkenswert gut darin sind,
absolute Trivialitäten auf eine Weise auszudrücken, dass sie besonders erkenntnisreich
klingen, von einer besonderen gedanklichen Tiefe ausgehen.
Ich würde sagen so, Richard David Precht ist so der Meister da drin und er schafft
das sogar ohne Lateinzitate, ja, der
muss immer nur irgendwelche Geisteswissenschaftler regelmäßig erwähnen,
deren Theorien er weiterentwickelt hat oder so, ja, um dann halt unglaublich,
eine unglaubliche Bedeutung seinen dann doch verhältnismäßig einfachen Erkenntnissen beizumessen.
Und es gibt Leute, die versuchen, vielleicht auch komplexere Zusammenhänge möglichst
einfach und verständlich darzustellen.
Das sind die, die meistens kein Latein gelernt haben in der Schule.
Etiam Peritus Erat,
Auch der Erfahrene irrt.
Wohin fällt der Affe? Vom Baum.
Du meinst, woher? Woher kommt der Affe?
Woher? Vom Baum.
Ich weiß es nicht. Also Latein, tut mir leid.
Das hat sich mir, da bin ich recht froh, dass ich mir das nie erschlossen hatte
und dass ich den Scheiß nicht gemacht habe.
Also mir ist durchaus klar, dass man in der Schule viele Sachen einfach nur
lernt, damit man irgendwas lernt.
Und dass das halt eher so eine Institution ist, die halt dafür da ist,
irgendwie dein Gehirn daran zu gewöhnen, da du die ganze Zeit mit unterschiedlichen
Herausforderungen und Reizen klarkommen musst und die gefälligst auch nicht in Frage stellt.
Aber mit Latein ist mir das ein bisschen zu weit gegangen, dieses Spiel.
Dann spielen wir das jetzt auch nicht.
Die Idee, lern mal eine Sprache, in der du dich mit niemandem unterhalten kannst,
die hat sich mir schon damals nicht erschlossen.
200 mal 20 Pixel. Even monkeys fall from trees.
200 mal 20 Pixel, das heißt 4.000 Dollar.
Für 4.000 Dollar hat sich The Book of Cool auf dieser Million Dollar Homepage eingekauft.
Und wenn du das jetzt mit der Stimme von Richard David Precht vortragen lässt,
dann klingt das tatsächlich wie eine bahnbrechende Erkenntnis.
Ja, das kann schon sein. Ich habe mir noch überlegt, wenn man vielleicht die
Domänen einfach kauft, ich meine, du hast ja mindestens 4.000 Dollar wert,
das linkt ja schon da drauf.
Und The Book of Cool, ich meine, wow, keine Ahnung, was da früher mal war.
Müssen wir noch mal nachschauen.
Ja, dann würde ich sagen, beschließen wir doch die Messe für heute.
Und wünschen euch eine wunderschöne Woche.
Bis bald.
Ciao, ciao.